في منطقة كابادوكيا التركية
المخبأة في الصخور المجوفة تقع
بعض أقدم الكنائس المسيحية في
العالم ، متحف غورام المفتوح عبارة عن
مجموعة من الأديرة والكنائس
التي يعود تاريخها إلى القرن الرابع
قبل
2.6 مليون سنة
انفجار بركاني  من جبل أو شيز المجاور
نتج عن تشكيل
مداخن خرافية على شكل فطر ، كل كنيسة
تشكل متحف جورهام في الهواء الطلق
تقع داخل كهف صخري ناعم منفصل
أكثر من 10 كنائس تشكل المتحف
داخل كل كنيسة هي لوحات جدارية
معروفة باسم  أمثلة على اللوحات الجدارية للكلاسيكيات القديمة
من فترة الفن البيزنطي
، تمكنت هذه اللوحات الرائعة
من الحفاظ على وضوحها وألوانها على
مر السنين بفضل عمليات
الترميم المتكررة في عام 1984 ، أصبح متحف جورهام في الهواء الطلق
أحد أول موقعين
في تركيا تم تصنيفهما على قائمة اليونسكو
موقع تراث عالمي ،
لكن تاريخ المتحف الواسع
والهياكل الفريدة التي جعلت منه
أحد أكثر الأماكن زيارة في كابادوكيا  الجذب إد